une mama ses parades juive un peu comme
la mienne qui est dans la cuisine en
train de verser un litre d'huile d'olive
dans une casserole comme ça et tout ça a
duré longtemps et tout à coup il ya son
mari qui rentrent qui lui dit cherry
qu'est ce qu'on mange et lui dit et je
sais pas encore
[Applaudissements]
les antisémites c'est sûr jean-marie
ratera ta femme blonde qui vient lui du
rouge sur le jour des faits comme ça à
usinor de l'autre côté
[Applaudissements]
sabah qu'il arrive on l'appelle audi
vient ta femme à la coucher il arrive en
courant la clinique et rend-il où on you
mobil-home ou visitez attendez attendez
faut qu'on vous dise un truc
le chirurgien l'arrivée du fou que je te
parle ton fils aîné mais il n'a pas de
bras et comment l apave rabat il n'a pas
de bras à l'ailé son bras ne pense pas
grave on va l'aimer quand même
il va pour aller dans la chambre il ya
temps c'est pas fini il n'a pas de
jambes et commencer une madeleine ces
coins là pas de jambes
bon bah si c'est pas grave je l'aimé
quand même si mon premier enfant peut
rien faire et entités mais attendez j'ai
pas fini a dit quoi à lui la pac est
[Rires]
rentré vous allez voir une grande
c'était qu'une eau et une oreille à
l'affiché du nord et du boss pas l'enjeu
ville et mais il prend lors elle dit je
t'aime office des salles par les jours
mais
[Applaudissements]
le mec qui fait quand on en parle c'est
me propre me saluer dans un ehpad
maisons de vieux cons on dit
vulgairement et il ya un vieux os pleine
nuit 3 heures du matin il hurle bazooka
la fermière de nuit elles arrivent a dit
monsieur arrêtez de lui rouler comme ça
allait réveiller tout le monde dans le
dans le bâtiment et elle soulève le vrai
elle dit en plus vous êtes fait pipi
dessus quoi pouvait pas demander le
pistolet le mec est divine
[Applaudissements]